what's up this is the bill from my
therapist oh yeah yeah so that's a lot
yeah well you know it's good it's good
to have a little bit of emotion come out
yes healthy you're great at making
really adorable creatures and then
making me cry over them oh I'm sorry
plus the other ones I love blurp oh yeah
blurp yeah blurb's good he's my favorite
I think he's a good addition to the
Guardians universe and I look forward to
the blurp Trilogy coming up hopefully
soon you heard it here first
are you ready
for One Last Ride
[Music]
ending this Trilogy did you always
Envision it as a Trilogy yeah and what
were some of the things that were
important to hit in the third one I
think I had certain characters that
needed to have an arc that I saw from
the beginning I mean I think all the
characters needed an arc but I think in
the third movie you see very clearly
that rocket nebula Peter Quill Drax
mantis they all have a very clear story
throughout the entire series a place
where they started and where they're
going I think that was important I think
it was important that you know you'll
watch a lot of franchise films and the
characters you know learn a lesson in
the first movie then we come back for a
second movie they learn exactly the same
lesson again come back for a third movie
they learn the same lesson again and I
wanted to make sure that this wasn't
that that these characters are evolving
and changing from movie to movie and
becoming you know different people what
did returning to do this mean to you
because there was a moment where it was
like is three gonna happen is it gonna
be you doing it and I imagine there was
maybe a point where you mourned it and
buried it and we're like a thousand
percent thousand percent didn't think I
was coming back so
um you know and listen I wasn't sure I
was going to come back when it was
offered to me I had to think about it
but the thing that made me come back was
of course my cast who have supported me
so much throughout all of this but
really the thing was I just needed to
finish Rocket's story I knew that he had
a story that I had in mind from the
beginning that was important to me and I
didn't want to leave the character
hanging with him seeing yandu's Arrow at
the end of volume two I felt like people
needed to know who he was completely and
what changes were in store for him
he didn't want to make things perfect
[Music]
he just hated things the way they uh
I love them so much and I love that you
get to really play on your own sandbox
here um it's really contained outside of
the rest of the MCU how important was
that to you well I think it's important
in telling a story I think more
importantly was that I've just seen so
many movies where they're trying to save
the universe and you don't really care
at the end of the day you know obviously
we would care if somebody's really
trying to save the universe but after
you see movie after movie after movie of
saving the universe every time it
becomes a lot more effective to see you
know saving an individual and in this
movie for a long time you're really
concerned about just rocket being saved
and I think it put me really propels the
plot forward a lot more than you know
some nonsense what is the most valuable
thing that you've learned throughout
this Trilogy that you will take with you
on to your next chapter I think the most
valuable thing I've learned is just that
really the thing that drives me that's
important to being a filmmaker is a
sense of creativity and play and you can
start to get distracted by results
by adulation or money or these other
things and all of those are sort of the
enemy
to creativity and storytelling not that
you know you can have those things or
not have those things but the important
part is focusing on the creativity and
the storytelling and the characters
first and foremost and I don't do what
you do at all but I get bogged down by
like what do I think people want versus
what do I want to do yeah how do you
balance that that's hard because you are
speaking to a massive audience so it is
a form of communication so I think it's
important to remember that it is an art
it's also a form of communication but
also to follow your gut with what you
feel is authentic and true I don't think
that you can do it without that yeah you
have the first half Bob in MCU okay now
what open the door how did that come to
be uh it wasn't in the script it was
just so the way I direct actors is a
little obnoxious I have a microphone
there's speakers on set and I'm just
constantly yelling at the actors to do
different things and often throwing them
lines and dialogue like people ask if
there's improv on Guardian sets there is
but literally ninety percent of it is me
offering new lines for people to see and
then them saying it on the moment some
of those things I keep like in a list so
that I can keep them fresher on set but
in this moment you know Chris says to
her open the door that was what was in
the script and then I just said hey say
open the you know effing door and uh he
did and it just it was funny and it was
uh when we put it in the cut it was
hilarious Marvel and Disney have been
fantastic with me they kind of let me do
whatever I want to do they give me free
reign and
um I did not think that they were going
to say okay to that particular thing but
that was nothing I love that you
introduce Adam Warlock
round
who I think people have been talking
about since the first Guardians yeah
who's it going to be like what is he
going to look like tell me about
bringing Will Poulter into this role
well I needed somebody who was you know
able you know in this movie Will Poulter
has been taken out of his cocoon a
little earlier than he should so his
brain isn't fully formed he's still a
child and so I needed somebody that
would have that childlike exuberance but
also knowing where the character is
going to go that was just you know
strapping young man that Will Poulter is
uh and he was able to just embody those
things incredibly well is there anyone
you would love to see him interact with
in the future I mean his power is pretty
commensurate with Thor and Captain
Marvel who are you know some of the most
powerful characters so maybe them what
would you like to see Adam Warlock learn
about for the first time
um what TV show would you show him I
think he'd probably be a big fan of
Dukes of Hazzard I think he'd dig that
show I think he'd get off on those good
old boys you know jumping and crashing
and you know swearing and drinking shine
literally the most random answer I could
love it what's the first movie that
comes to my mind that's the one that had
a more like I said Banner bumper yeah
like apparently not
I talked to Bradley which was so awesome
I feel like I hadn't really gotten to
talk to him yeah yeah rocket and he was
like I go over James sells me
and I was like well we need to see your
beautiful blue eyes on the screen would
you use him in the flesh at some point
somewhere oh well who knows what's
happening yeah okay I love Bradley
[Music]
thank you